now this course is part of the app
entrepreneurship nanodegree lots of
entrepreneurs work in teams but many
also work alone so it's important to
think about which of these circles of
feedback you can access as an individual
to think about that let's first look at
how you access each of the circles of
feedback the first circle is pretty
simple if you work at a company you can
walk down the hall there's an ask
someone or if you're working on your own
you can ask a friend to sit down on a
couch with you since you only need 10 or
15 minutes of someone's time to get a
good sense of how they would react to
your app you can usually get experts in
the field are often slightly more
difficult to get in touch with and our
best reached by using Twitter email or
phone look for experts that are in your
area or wait until you have an
interactive online prototype like the
one will be building with envision the
third and fourth circles are often best
reached through guerrilla prototyping
you can often find someone who matches
your target demographic at a coffee shop
and it's possible to offer them coffee
in exchange for looking at your
prototype now which of these can you do
as a solo entrepreneur